questions
after please donna marsh o'connor
september 11th families for peaceful
tomorrows
okay next we're going to hear from
imam abdulbaki of the islamic leadership
council of new york
i greet you in the islamic greetings of
peace assalamu alaikum
i would like to say first and foremost
that there is today a dark cloud over
our heads but there is indeed a dark
cloud
over the america and that dark cloud is
the cloud
of intolerance as well as racism
which is being perpetuated by a small
minority
who are trying to perpetuate hatred
against the islamic community on
9 11 muslims lost their lives
in the twin towers it is said 2
to 300 people lost their lives who were
muslims from africa
from asia from latin america all of this
talk
about the masjid at ground zero is
ludicrous
because of the fact that muslims have
been praying in new york city
for many many years we live here we are
part and parcel of the fabric of new
york city
there's a monster on warren street
there's a mustard on west broadway
and there was even a masjid in tower two
of the world trade center
that people used to go there and worship
and transit from new jersey to new york
so therefore those individuals who are
perpetuating all of this
ignorance hate are trying to stir up
within america
sentiments will to do harm to the
credibility of our nation
america is better than that we're a
nation found
upon pluralism we have always been a
nation in which everyone has looked
towards america
for freedom justice and equality
and the muslim community expects nothing
less than that
we will continue to be a part of this
environment
and we encourage our fellow new yorkers
to be
understanding that that group which is
called
the stop the summation of america
shouldn't be
condemned because of its racism it is
sowing
the seeds of hate and discard
it is confusing the issue what is the
issue in america
the issue is jobs homelessness
revitalizing the economic community
putting america back to work helping our
society
be foremost in terms of economic growth
and development in the world
thank you thank you thank you imam
next we're going to hear from donna
lieberman of the new york civil
liberties union
thank you i'm donna lieberman executive
director of the new york civil liberties
union
and i'm proud to stand here today with
new york neighbors for american values
to support the principles of religious
freedom diversity
and equality that hang in the balance in
the controversy
over the park 51 islamic cultural center
we are committed to resisting the
efforts to push part 51
out of downtown and we reject the
refrain
of freedom of religion but not in my
backyard
let there be no mistake as residents of
lower manhattan
the nyclu office is a stone's throw from
ground zero
and one of our chapter board members
john perry lost his life on september
11th
we share the pain the hurt and yes
even the lingering fear caused by the
september 11th attacks
but we unequivocally reject the
political posturing
the fear-mongering and the crude
stereotyping
that seek to demonize the project whose
goal is to build bridges
among the faiths and to to banish a
community
cultural and recreation center for
people of all faiths
simply because it contains a place for
muslims
to worship religious freedom
is a core american value for hundreds of
years
religious pluralism and tolerance have
strengthened our nation
we stand here today to boldly oppose
religious discrimination
and to resist those who seek to exchange
our most precious values for political
advantage
we applaud those government officials
including mayor bloomberg
who have stood up for religious liberty
and defended the right of private
citizens
to build a muslim community center in
lower manhattan
opponents of the center now tell us that
they support religious freedom
but they say it's insensitive to build
the center two blocks
from ground zero they're certainly
entitled to their opinion but when that
opinion is rooted
in misinformation and cultural
stereotypes
that fail to distinguish law-abiding
muslims
from the terrorists who committed the 9
11 atrocities in the name of islam
we must speak out this type of group
blame
fuels prejudice and has already blocked
other mosque projects that are nowhere
near ground zero
and it cannot be allowed to drive public
policy
or to drive away a religious group
adhering to our constitution is not
optional
we can't abandon our values to protect
the sensitivities
of newt gingrich or for that matter
harry reid
the new york civil liberties union and
the aclu have defended the right of all
religious denominations
from major faiths to marginalized
religions
to establish places of worship and to
pray
or not pray as they choose
preventing muslims or any group from
freely protecting their
practicing their faith is
unconstitutional and
goes against the very core of american
freedom
those who oppose park 51 have every
right to speak their minds
but in the end discrimination is a
losing proposition
if we betray our ideals we'll hand a
victory to those
who seek to undermine our nation and to
those who believe as i do
that ground zero is hallowed ground i
say
let us honor the memories of those who
died
not by abandoning our values but by
standing up for them
and for those who are uncomfortable with
it
we say let's do that even if it hurts
thank you next we're going to hear from
donna scopper
of the judson memorial church and the
new sanctuary
movement
let us pray almighty god
you whom some call jesus and others call
christ you whom some call allah
others yahweh ruach spirit energy
force you for whom
many are estranged
and no longer dare your name because so
much
that is mean and unworthy has been done
in it
draw near now and teach us the meaning
of truly hallowed ground amen
what is hallowed ground
surely hallowed ground is a place where
someone has died
and blood has been shed and sorrow
and tragedy lurk
hallowed ground is also a place where
life goes
on and where people transcend
the forces of violence and difficulty
and come together as cultures
as centers as forces of freedom
to truly hallow what has happened
among us as a great nation and a great
people
we need to go forward in love
mutual respect with the constitution
at our side the idea
that we would hallow ground by losing
religious liberties of any kind shape or
form
is to desecrate to hallow ground
i call your attention to the great words
of a great president
spoken at gettysburg november 19
1863 you know the speech
he said in a larger sense we cannot
dedicate nor consecrate we cannot really
hallow
ground it is rather for us here
to go to the great task remaining before
us
that we highly resolve the dead do not
die
in vain that this nation under god shall
have a new birth of freedom
and that government of the people by the
people for the people will not
perish from this earth this is what as
at stake
in this tremendously important
conversation about religious liberty
we hallow ground by remaining
a people who will not let go of
religious liberty for me
for you or any faith thank
thank you now we will hear from rabbi
arthur waskow
of the shalom center
shalom salam
peace people ask me why
is it that i the shalom center
and hundreds of rabbis and other jewish
leaders
who have come together with us
in a public statement supporting
park 51 cordoba house in lower manhattan
why well i could of course
quote the torah love your neighbor
as yourself don't do to your neighbors
what you would find hateful if they did
it
to you the ahafta
kamoja well i could quote and we did
quote the very first president of the
united states
writing a letter to a synagogue in rhode
island
saying to bigotry no sanction
to persecution no assistance
but for me the deepest teaching came
when i was seven years old
from my grandmother standing in a line
at the kocher butcher shop in baltimore
and overhearing two other women on the
line
talking with contempt about
african americans the schwarzes they
said in yiddish
and she interrupted them she said
you must not talk like that that is the
way
they talked about us in europe and this
is america and you must not talk like
that
and we must not like act like that
either
it is not only that
cordoba house has a constitutional right
to create a cultural center in lower
manhattan
it is that it is right it is wise
for them to do that because by doing
that they lift a beacon
to new york city to america to the world
a beacon of the best the deepest
of islam the islam that seeks peace
that practices dialogue the islam
that their beacon shows is not
in its great overwhelming majority
a religion of hatred and violence but a
hatred of dialogue and peacemaking
and open invitation they appeal to
cordoba
which in jewish tradition is the place
where one of our greatest teachers
studied together with christians
together with muslims
and jews together in cordoba in
andalusia
in the golden age we call it of jewish
history
that appeal that beacon is what
all of us need today and we affirm it
we affirm it in the name of the one
we affirm it in the name of shalom
peace and now we will hear from faisal
ali of the council
on american islamic relations
good afternoon everyone my name is faiza
ali and i'm from the new york chapter of
the council on american islamic
relations
the nation's largest muslim civil rights
advocacy group
americans have the right to freely
practice their faith
without intimidation and discrimination
including the constitutional right to
build houses of worship
anywhere in the country it is this
founding principle
that has sparked a nationwide
conversation over a proposed muslim
ymca a few blocks from ground zero
revealing a disturbing wave of
anti-muslim sentiment
just last night we learned of a new york
city cab driver
that was stabbed by a passenger who
allegedly asked if he was muslim
opponents to park 51 continue to smear
all things muslim and justify their
calls to move their project
away from the 911 site by erroneously
linking
the criminals responsible for the
attacks to the organizers
and its supporters discontinuation of
collective guilt
the notion that american muslims should
be treated as second-class citizens
in our own home is not only false it is
un-american
and should be rejected muslims aren't
newcomers to lower manhattan
in fact the community has been
worshiping at a mosque
a few blocks from ground zero since the
early
1970s we will not let extremists
and opportunists exploit the tragedy of
9 11
to create divisions amongst new yorkers
and distort the true
purpose around the center part 51
will be a space for dialogue and
cultural exchange
amongst members of all faiths and people
of all backgrounds
it will also be a facility that meets
the needs of the growing new york city
muslim community
including a space for a gym a swimming
pool
an auditorium a prayer room and even
a memorial for the victims of 9 11.
amidst the vile attacks there have in
fact been voices of reason
that have seen past the anti-muslim
smears that have clouded this issue
in his address to the community at an
iftar last night
mayor bloomberg said let me declare that
we
in new york are jews and christians and
muslims and we always have been
and above all that we are americans with
the equal right to pray
where we choose there is nowhere in the
five boroughs that is off limits
to any religion we thank mayor bloomberg
for his unequivocal support
for the rights of muslim new yorkers and
for taking a principled stand
that reaffirms religious liberty for all
not just some
anything less of that would be a mockery
of our constitution
thank you on behalf of common cause
i would like to say that the hundreds of
thousands
of americans that we represent around
the country
understand that a diverse and vibrant
america
living by its constitutional principles
is among our strongest weapons
against the fear and hatred that feed
terrorism
we reject efforts to inject
misinformation
fear and stereotyping into our politics
and to the politicians who seek to make
this election season
about fear and divisiveness we join with
the imam
and we say talk about the real problems
facing
our society and our country we have
fiscal challenges
we have social challenges we have not
yet recovered from the great recession
what are you going to do to help the
people of america
that's what you should be talking about
not where a cultural center is going to
be located
in downtown new york shame on you
and now we'll take questions
and would you please identify yourself
before your question
this is something which we see all the
time at common cause
and those of us who work on good
government issues and in politics
a isolated statement taken out of
context
misconstrued twisted and made to stand
for something other
than what the speaker intended and we
ask you of the press
to be more critical more skeptical and
look at the entire context
how many times do we have to go through
a press frenzy around a misstatement
we can tick off the number of
individuals
in this administration and other
administrations who have been tarred
with isolated statements that don't
represent
their life's work and certainly it
appears that the imam
is a victim of exactly that
who are you um the coalition
actually was formed very quickly because
we felt
that this controversy couldn't really
continue on
and so when it picked up speed and
seemed not to be dying
of the misinformation and its own weight
we felt that it was necessary for new
yorkers
to step forward and clarify as
the frenzy mounted and more
misinformation was put out
we felt we couldn't just ignore it we
had to move forward
we have some specific plans we will stay
together as a group we are very broad
and diverse
we are gathering members every single
day organizationally and individually
i have no idea what the top number on
this coalition will be
because the response has been
overwhelming um what we
are planning to do we have a website
which is new york neighbors dot
o r g n y neighbors dot o r g
we are planning a candlelight vigil on
september 10th
we will be joining in with all of the
extraordinary
memorials and services which take place
on september 11th it's not our place to
replace
these extraordinary services and
memorials
which have been going on in some cases
for nine years
and we will also be joining in on
a peace walk which is happening on
september 12th
there will be a letter writing campaign
i believe and we will
also remain as a coalition to be a voice
for american values and reason in this
frenzy
yes ma'am who are you
911 family yes raise your hand
there isn't there isn't a 911 family
member i can think of who is not
experiencing post 9 11 pain
and i would you know i i would tell you
personally i understand that pain
every time one of you people decides
for whatever reason to show the image of
the towers falling
you know that produces post 911
pain as an individual family member i
will tell you
that there are times i wish you didn't
have the right to free speech
because if you really cared about us you
wouldn't do that
and suddenly now when the stakes are so
high
we're worried about individual family
members
and their pain i am not going to stand
here and tell you that
i am not sympathetic to that pain i am
but i am also thinking about the
consequences for
us is as americans if we lose
this debate that will be a greater pain
we've already seen across the country
anti-muslim violence rallies protests
against
mosques so this is not just
a protest against the ground at ground
zero there's too much at stake 3 000
family members died that day three
thousand and that is just the the round
number
and one of the things that pains me is
when you round out those numbers
my kid was only one i left her there
and i will tell you that i am not
leaving behind my country people who
speak
up for american civil liberties now
are really living what we were always
told in this mythic way
america meant so i will say to you
please don't try to place 911 family
members
against one another we're not at least
i'm not
okay and i'm thinking again about the
number of muslim people
in this country who are raising children
in the center of this debate and i'm
thinking
you know does my personal you know
twitch
does my personal twitch justify
painting people who are trying to raise
american children as muslim people in
this nation
because i don't know what you're trying
to get me to say
but from my point of view that
sensitivity
let's think about the generations we
want to bring up my kid died when she
was 29
and i don't know if any of you have
children
but when you when you lose a child no
matter what age
you always wonder if you were a good
enough parent
and i spent an awful lot of my
daughter's life trying to make her into
the idealized respectful version well
she loved danger she loved the world
trade center she loved new york city
and she loved the new york yankees and i
will tell you
that one of the things she said to me
shortly before she died because she was
pregnant
is thank you mom for teaching us what
everyday life
is when it is the seed of racism because
she was hearing conversations
that i had taught my kids to be
sensitive to
so when i think of sensitivity that's
how i think about it
who do we have to look out for we're 3
000 families strong unfortunately
and we take up a lot of different
perspectives
but i would ask in terms of sensitivity
you know darn well
that any politician who wants to invoke
doesn't care about our sensitivities
when he or she puts
into their ads to be re-elected the
tower is falling
so why is this something you're suddenly
all so worried
about now you know i'm so happy to hear
the rabbi say
and the way my grandfather used to say
about racists in our family
stop it it's not okay here
stop it one of the things which we will
i'm sorry we can't hold on one second i
just wanted to say one thing that we
will be doing on the website
is providing a list of resources for
different
topics for you the press of spokespeople
that you can talk to
i'm sorry
no um next question please
separate later we can we can do that
later
for specific um interviews but are there
other general questions
or questions for others part of the
coalition
if not thank you very much